as total 42 comes to an end new law is
being enacted anyone caught crossing the
border illegally won't be allowed to
return to the U.S for five years
[Music]
title 42 is a law that enables the
United States to stop entries into the
country to prevent the spread of
communicable disease it was introduced
in the Trump era ostensively to stop the
spread of covert 19. Joe Biden has
officially abolished what remained of
America's borders in turn the United
States into a Dumping Ground for illegal
aliens it allowed the authorities to
quickly Deport migrants to Mexico or
back to their countries of origin
since title 42 was introduced early in
the pandemic it's been used to deport
migrants more than 2 million times
it's expiring because the public health
emergency is coming to an end as covered
recedes so does the need for title 42
but what is clear is that there has been
a huge increase in numbers gathering at
the border officials report ten thousand
and Rising per day border infrastructure
is straining under the numbers cities
like El Paso and Texas
have declared a state of emergency
the Biden Administration is sending 1500
active duty troops to the border to help
the National Guard in managing the
situation
as title 42 comes to an end new law is
being enacted anyone arriving at the
border won't be allowed in if they
haven't first applied online
or sort asylum in the country through
which they reach the United States
caught crossing the border illegally
won't be allowed to return to the U.S
for five years
and if they do they face criminal
prosecution